HEARING FOR SENATE BILLS IT IS
GOOD TO BE BACK AT THE CAPITOL
AND CONTINUING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING PROCESS. I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN TODAY BY THANKING
EVERYONE WHO HAVE WORK EVERYONE
WHOSE WORK SO INCREDIBLY HARD
TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO
HEAR BILLS DURING THIS VERY-
DIFFERENT TIME. AND OUR NEW
NORMAL YOU SEE THAT WE ARE ALL
MASS STEP AND WE ARE PRACTICING
SOCIAL DISTANCING TO KEEP
EVERYONE SAFE AND I JUST
APPRECIATE EVERYONE IN THE
SENATE WHO HAS DONE SUCH AN
AMAZING JOB TO KEEP US SAFE.
AND ALLOW US TO PRACTICE YES WE
SHOULD GIVE THEM A HAND. IN
RESPONSE TO COVERED NINETEEN
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING. AND HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES. TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY. OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WE
COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING. INTIMATE DEBATE
REMOTELY SENATOR GLAZER WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
SENATOR BILL WHO HAS A BILLABLE
ALSO BE PRESENTING REMOTELY.
FOR MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE
MEET YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
ARE IT PERSONNEL WILL MUTE AND
UNMUTE THE VIDEO SERVICE WHEN
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. THIS WILL
GREATLY AID ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I HAVE SAID
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION. YOU USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THE BILL NUMBER TWO WHICH
YOU ARE REFERRING. WELCOME
SENATOR MCGUIRE. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. TWO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS HELLO I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. THE MORNING
SENATOR LANG LANG LANG YOU ARE
GOING TO BE RIGHT THERE. ONE
DOWN VERY GOOD FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
HERE. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 1-844-291-6364 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT NINE
EIGHT SEVEN NINE THREE FOUR.
WILL REMOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
THE MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING AND THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE DURING THIS PROCESS. I
WILL MEAN THE COURT WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER. AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS AND IF YOU
TECHNICAL ISSUES AS WE PROCEED
TODAY. PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
BE PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. THE COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY HAS CREATED
AN UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION
LEADING TO SIGNIFICANT DEMANDS
ON OUR STUDENTS FAMILIES. AND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS. OUR
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES ARE
IMPACTED IN BOTH. IN TERMS OF
BOTH PERSONNEL AND BUDGETS.
CONSIDERING THE DIRE SITUATION
WHICH MANY STUDENTS SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES FIND THEMSELVES. HAVE
ASKED SENATORS TO PARTNER BILL
PACKAGES BACK TO INCLUDE ONLY
BILLS. THAT ADDRESS THE MOST
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES AND THAT
TO NOT ADD RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
COSTS. AS A RESULT WE WILL HEAR
FAR FEWER BILLS THEN WE WOULD
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES. I
DEEPLY APPRECIATE ALL MEMBERS
COOPERATION. THERE ARE FIVE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA THREE
OF THOSE BILLS ARE ARMED
CONSENT. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
TO RECOGNIZE THOSE MEMBERS WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IN
OUR DISTRICT OFFICES AND WHO
WILL NOT BE- PARTICIPATING
HERE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED MADAM
SECRETARY CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. SENATOR LEYVA HERE.
SENATOR WILK PRESIDENT. WILL
CARE. CENTER CHIANG YEAR CHIANG
HIM SENATOR ALSO ALSO HERE SIR
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE HERE CENTER
PAN YEAH. WONDERFUL MEMBERS
IT'S GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WE ARE GOING TO START WITH
OUR FIRST AUTHOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND HE HAS SB EIGHT
OH FIVE WHICH IS BEFORE US
TODAY SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR A CONVENING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING UNDER-
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCE AND
I APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS SO
LEADERSHIP- I WAS ONE OF THOSE
SENATORS WHO I THINK HAD SEVEN
EDUCATION BILLS AND DROP SIX OF
A MAN SO HERE I AM WITH THE-
THE ONE BILL THAT WAS IN MY
OPINION DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC SO I'M- PLEASED TO-
PRESENTED. I ALSO WANT TO GIVE
A SHOUT OUT TO- THE BURBANK-
UNIFIED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND THEIR PRESIDENT DIANA ****
WHO SUGGESTED THIS BILL TO HER
SUPERINTENDENT WHO ALSO
RESPONDED POSITIVELY AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I APPRECIATE
ABOUT SB EIGHT OH FIVE IS THAT
IT CAME FROM. THE TEACHER SIDE
THE- THE LABOR SIDE AND IT WAS
IN BRACE BY THE MANAGEMENT SIDE
AS SOMETHING TO- TO CONSIDER
AND SO I THINK THAT GIVES IT A
SPECIAL POSITIVE CIRCUMSTANCE
AND IT WAS AN OUTGROWTH OVER
THE FIRES WHERE MANY A SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES LIVED IN AREAS OF THE
STATE. WERE EVACUATED- DUE TO A
NATURAL DISASTER WHOSE SCHOOLS
WERE STILL WORKING BECAUSE THEY
WERE IN A DIFFERENT PART OF THE
STATE AND SO THEY WERE FORCED
TO USE THEIR SICK TIME THOUGH
THEY WERE IF YOU WAITED IN STE
THAT'S THE CRUX OF THE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE TRYING. TO
TAL. YOU KNOW OUR PLEASE.
WHETHER THEY'RE A CLASSIFIED.
MAINTENANCE FOR FACULTY
TEACHERS GET AFFECTED BY THESE
NATURAL DISASTERS INCLUDING
PANDEMICS AND SO WE'VE INCLUDED
THAT AS WELL- EIGHT OH FIVE
PROHIBITS A SCHOOL DISTRICT
FROM ACQUIRING EMPLOYEES TO
USER PAID LEAVE IF I'M ABLE TO
REPORT TO WORK ADDITIONALLY
EIGHT OH FIVE CLARIFIES THAT
SCHOOLS WILL RECEIVE THEIR
EIGHTY EIGHT. WHICH I BELIEVE
WAS WORK OF SENATOR JACKSON
YEARS AGO TO MAKE SURE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE MADE WHOLE
AND WE CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCING
PANDEMICS TO COVERT NINETEEN-
AND OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS WE
THINK THIS IS A LAUDABLE
PROPOSAL TO BE CONCERNED- FOR
THIS LOOK THIS BODY I TO WILL
ENSURE THAT EMPLOYEES- DON'T
FACE FINANCIAL HARM. WHEN A
NATURAL DISASTER OCCURS THE
COMMITTEE HAS SUGGESTED A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE
TAKING ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND SO MY STAFF- WAS
PLEASED TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
THANK YOU SO WILL TAKE ALL OF
YOUR CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS-
WHICH I THINK MAKE THE BILL
STRONGER- WITH ME I BELIEVE.
VIA CONFERENCE IS- TRISH
TRISTEN BROWN FROM C. F. T.
ANCEPT BRAMBLE FROM CTA WHO
WILL EXPRESS SOME SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. AND SO I THINK THIS
SOLVES A PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED BY NATURAL
DISASTERS AND- I KNOW THERE
FISCAL ISSUES WHICH WE WILL
ADDRESS IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE I'M CERTAINLY GOING
TO. BE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SEE HOW IT
FITS INTO THE OVERALL EDUCATION
BUDGET. BUT ON THE POLICY
MERITS I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO WELL DONE ALRIGHT WE
THINK- I'M NOT SURE WHERE-
TRISTEN BROWN AND SETH OR- HAVE
THEY CALLED IN ON A LINE. AND
DOES THE MODERATOR HAVE ANYBODY
WAITING. BUT NEITHER OF THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE- JOIN THE
CONFERENCE AS OF YET WE DO
HAVE- A COUPLE THAT ARE IN Q.
AT THIS TIME WILL GO TO LINE AT
NUMBER TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE WAR DURAN FOREST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES THE SENSATION OVER
HERE AND PART OF THE- THANK YOU
DORIS THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU WILL NOW
GO TO LINE TWELVE FIND TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO SHALL
CAST OF THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION OFF ON THE
PART OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON
IN SUPPORT. NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY VERY GOOD I DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
THAT WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
LOOKS LIKE NO ONE IS THERE. ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANYONE HAVE
EXCUSE ME THOSE IN OPPOSITION
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. IF YOU ARE NOT
POSITION OF THE BILL ON THE
PHONE LINES PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
MISTER MODERATOR ALL RIGHT NOW
WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- TEN FORTY I WANT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- CERTAINLY ONE
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
AND THE IDEA THAT- TEACHERS
SHOULD NOT BE PENALIZED BECAUSE
THEY WERE. LIVING IN A DISASTER
AREA. I THINK THE ONE ISSUE AND
I'M SURE THAT YOU'LL- DRESS
THAT PERHAPS IN THE AND
APPROPRIATIONS IS. I DO I DO
RECOGNIZE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- MAY BE A SITUATION
WHERE THEY MAY HAVE EACHERS
WHO DO LIVE IN ITS ASTORIA BUT
THEY THEMSELVES ARE NOT AND
THEY HAVE TO CONTINUE
OPERATIONS. AND AT SOME POINT
IN TIME YOU KNOW. RECOGNIZING
THAT THE TEACHERS THEMSELVES
CANNOT BE IN THE CLASSROOM-
MEANING THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S GONNA HAVE TO FIND.
SOMEONE ELSE TO PROVIDE THE
TEACHING AND THEREFORE- MAY
NEED SOME FINANCIAL SUPPORT
EVENTUALLY. IF IT'S FOR
PROLONGED PERIOD OF TIME SO I
HOPE YOU'LL ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
IS THIS BILLS MOVING FORWARD-
BUT ONLY SUPPORT THE BILL WOULD
BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL AT
THIS TIME. IF IT'S APPROPRIATE
GREAT. THANK YOU LAWCENTER PAN
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. GOOD I
KNOW THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO. IT CAN GET PRETTY
COMPLICATED- I KNOW WHEN IT
COMES TO JURISDICTIONS AND WHO
REPRESENTS WHERE AN WHO WORKS
WHERE- SO THIS GUY TO BE SORT
OF A RECIPROCAL. UNDERSTANDING
I THINK THAT GETS ADOPTED BUT-
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING IT UP I KNOW THIS IS-
SPECIALLY SUPPORTER BECAUSE- IN
ADDITION TO THE TEACHERS
THERE'S- REGULAR. CLASSIFIED
WORKERS WHO ARE EVEN MORE
IMPACTED- BECAUSE OF THEIR
LOWER SALARY SO ANYWAY THANK
YOU I SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR DRAWS SO- I DON'T
SEE ANY MORE QUESTIONS HERE AT
THE DAIS AND IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE SO- CENTER GLAZER YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS REMOTELY. OKAY
VERY GOOD- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE NOW I- IT'S SORT OF
IRONIC THAT THE BILL HAD ITS
GENESIS PRIOR TO KOBE BUT HAS
BEEN MADE ALL MORE REAL- DUE TO
COVET AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME PRESENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER PORTANTINO THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN. A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB EIGHT ZERO FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR. SENATOR LEYVA HI. HI
CENTER WILK HI. WILK HI. CENTER
CHIANG. CENTER CHIANG HI
TORONTO TORONTO I REQUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE PAN PAN HI. ALL
RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX
ZERO EXCUSE ME THANK YOU SIR
ALRIGHT WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO SENATOR PELL WHO IS
TESTIFYING REMOTELY I HAVE TO
SAY I'M SO IMPRESSED WITH ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES AND ALL THIS
LEARNING HOW TO DO THINGS A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY SO SENATOR
BILL WE'RE GOING TO GO TO YOU-
PLEASE PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE
READY WE CAN SEE YOU AND I
THINK WE'LL BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU BUT SURE NUMBERS-
APPRECIATE DARK 20% THIS BILL-
REMOTELY. AND I'M PRESENTING SB
EIGHT SIXTY. THIS IS A BILL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE UP FAST FOR
A COMPLETION. AMONG FOSTER YOU
THAT'S THE- FREE APPLICATION
FOR FEDERAL STUDENT ASSISTANCE.
OF FORM THAT YOU FILL OUT TO
GET YOUR STUDENT AID IN
COLLEGES AND- THIS ONE SURE
THEY HAVE SUPPORT TO ACCESS THE
FINANCIALLY THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE ARE RIGHT-NOW- MORE THAN EVER FOSTER YOU
NEED OUR SUPPORT. AND WHEN
CRISIS IS HAPPENED FOSTER YOU
FOR OFTEN GET THE HARDEST AND
ARE UNFORTUNATELY NOT A GIVEN
THE NECESSARY SUPPORT TO ACCESS
VARIOUS RESOURCES MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL. AND WE HAVE
AN URGENCY TO EMPOWER FOSTER
YOUTH TO PURSUE A POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND GAIN
HIGH QUALITY AND RELIABLE JOBS
IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE TAKEN A
LOT OF STEPS IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO TAKE BOLD ACTIONS TO INVEST
MORE FUNDING IN FINANCIAL AID
SPECIFICALLY FOR FOSTER YOU.
HOWEVER THE ADVOCATES IN THE
FIELDS OF IDENTIFIED THIS FAST
WELL COMPLETION. CONTINUES TO
BE A BARRIER FOR STUDENTS. TO
ACCESS THE FUNDS THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO OUR RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA FORTY PERCENT- OF
THE FOSTER YOU- ONLY RECEIVED
THE FEDERAL. PELL GRANT FOR
FOSTER YOU OF THIS OF FEDERAL
FUNDS AND ONLY ELEVEN PERCENT-
ACTUALLY GET CAL GRANTS SO
THAT'S A PRETTY BAD RATE AND-
I'M SURE THOSE OF YOU OF
FAMILIAR WITH THIS FAST FOR
FORM. NO HELP COMPLEX AND
FRUSTRATING IT IS THIS THINK OF
WHAT IT MEANS T OUR FOSTER YOU
SO COMPLETING AT IS A FIRST
STEP AND WE LEAVE FOSTER YOU TO
NAVIGATE IT ON THEIR OWN- WHICH
RESULTS IN INCOMPLETE
APPLICATIONS AND OF COURSE THEY
OFTEN MISS THE DEADLINES. ARE
THIS BILL DOES. IS TWO THINGS
IT FIRST OF ALL PROVIDES THE
ROLE OF THE FOSTER YOU'VE
COORDINATING PROGRAM TO
INCLUDE. IS TO SUPPORT THE FAST.
SHIN AMONG US YOU AND A WHAT
ALSO ADD THE FAST FOCUS RATE TO
THE BY AN RATE. OF RIGHT NOW
ALL OF WITH THE VIRUS SO THE
FASTER YOUTH WHEN THEY DON'T
APPLY FOR. THESE GRANTS WHAT
THEY HAVE IS EMPLOYMENT LOT ON
DON'T HAVE EMPLOYMENT ANYMORE
BUT RETAIN THEIR WAY THROUGH
COLLEGE BY WORKING. AND THE
EMPLOYMENT HAS DRPPED AWAY
FROM HOME THEY HAVE NO FAMILIES
AND- THE ONLY THE ONLY CHOICE
THEY HAVE IS TO DROP OUT SO WE
NEED TO HAVE THE GRANTS THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO. AVAILABLE TO HOME
AND INCREASE THE COMPLETION
RATE FOR THERE ARE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES SO WE I'D LIKE TO
TURN OVER TIME WITH SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR. OF DEBBIE RAUSCHER FROM
THE JOHN BIRCH BURDEN ADVOCATES
AND EMERALD EVANS WHO'S WILLING
TO SHARE HER STORY IN THE
FOSTER USE SYSTEM. HOW THIS
BELT BILL WOULD HAVE BENEFITTED
HER AND OTHERS SO THANK YOU
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR BELL- MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE DEBBIE
ROWE SURE ON THE LINE AND
EMERALD EVAN ON THE LINE.
CHECKING FOR YOU ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU. DEBBIE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN CAN YOU SPEAK.
PLEASE FLAT YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN HEAR YOU YES. OKAY MY
NAME IS TERRY ROZIER AND I'M
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YEARS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. AS CENTER BELL SHARED
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT LARGE
NUMBERS OF FOSTER TO ENROLL IN
COLLEGE ARE MISSING OUT ON
CRUCIAL FINANCIALLY. COMPLETING
THE FASTER IS THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS OBTAINING FINANCIAL AID
HOWEVER MANY FOSTER YOUTH ARE
LEFT TO NAVIGATE THIS PROCESS
WITHOUT GUIDANCE RESULTING IN
LOW COMPLETION RATES. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MY ORGANIZATION
CREATED THE FOSTER YOUTH STOPS
AT CHALLENGE PARTNERING WITH
COUNTY SAUCE DO SERVICES
COORDINATED PROGRAMS ARE FY IS
SHE PEES. THE RATE OF SOUTH TO
COMPLETION AMONG HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS IN FOSTER CARE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITIES ALREADY
ARTICULATED FOR THESE PROGRAMS
IN STATUTE TO SUPPORT POST
SECONDARY MATRICULATION. WITHIN
FIFTY COUNTY NOW PARTICIPATE
AND THIS VOLUNTARY EFFORTS HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE IN TRAFFIC
COMPLETION RATES FROM 45% 258%
OVER TWO YEARS LEVERAGING OVER
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID. COMING NINETEEN
POSES A SPECIAL RISK TO HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS WITH EXPERIENCE
IN FOSTER CARE HOPING TO ENROLL
IN COLLEGE. STUDIES AFTER
HURRICANE KATRINA SHOW THAT
WOULD SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES SHUT
DOWN THEIR CAMPUSES THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH WERE THE
ONES MOST LIKELY. TO BE
PERMANENTLY KNOCKED OFF TRACK.
THEREFORE ACTUALLY PIECES MADE
ENORMOUS PROGRESS OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS WITH STAFF TO
COMPLETION AND SB EIGHT SIXTY
WILL CODIFY THIS WORK INTO LAW.
INSURING THAT THE PROGRESS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN AS A STATE WILL
NOT BE REVERSED. AT A TIME WHEN
THESE RESOURCES WILL BE NEED IT
THE MOST. THE STUDENTS IN
FOSTER CARE BECOME INCREASINGLY
DISCONNECTED FROM HIGH SCHOOLS
AS A RESULT OF THE CRISIS. USE
HER IN THE CARE AND CUSTODY OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NOW
MORE THAN EVER THE STEADY HAND
OF EXPERTS. OKAY FILL THE GAP
LEFT BY THE ABSENCE OF PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE- EMERALD ARE YOU READY TO
GO. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU. PLEASE PROCEED. I HI
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE WITH
YOU. MY NAME IS AMBROSE EVANS
AND I'M TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD
AND CURRENTLY A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE. I WAS RAISED
IN FOSTER CARE FROM THE AGE OF
FIVE AND- H. NOW AT TWENTY ONE.
THROUGHOUT MY FOSTER CARE. I
INTENDED A DOZEN SCHOOLS WHICH
IS VERY CHALLENGING FOR ME.
BECAUSE MY SWELLING WITH
INCONSISTENT. THE CONTENT OF
THE CURRICULUM AND TEACHING OUT
OFTEN VERY IT WAS VERY HARD TO
JUDGE ONE FORCE TO LOOK COOL IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE TERM. MOVING
THAT MUCH ALSO MADE IT HARDER
FOR ME TO DEVELOP A
RELATIONSHIP. BUT I DON'T
SUPPORTED AND MY PEERS. AND I
THINK WITH MY HEAD FOR YEARS I
WOULD FULLY AWARE OF MY COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITIES. AND HOW TO CARE
FOR COLLEGE INCLUDING APPLYING
FOR ADMISSION PICKING. AT THE
AT T. AND CRUCIALLY APPLYING
FOR FINANCIAL AID. NUMBER ANY
OF THAT I THINK ON A FINE FOR
FINANCIAL AID INCLUDING NOT
UNDERSTANDING TERMINOLOGY. NOT
KNOWING HOW TO ACCESS THE
DOCUMENT THAT I NEEDED TO
APPLY. AND NOT EVEN
UNDERSTANDING THE FULL SCOPE OF
WHAT FINANCIAL AID WHEN. OR IF
IMPORTANT. I WAS FORCED. THAT I
WAS MAKE SURE HELPFUL. AND WITH
A TO RESET A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS ARE MY OWN. BUT I HAD
SEEN ANY MY PEERS FACT THE NOT
HOW THE HAPPY. TO PURSUE
GETTING THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION. MICHAEL AT THE-
BILL IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WOULD
ALLOW FONG YOU HAVE A RELY
SUPPORT SYSTEM. THAT YOU
PREPARE COLLEGE DESPITE MANAGE
THAT THEY MAKE. HAVING
FINANCIAL A LIVE. AS THE QUICK
TO GET THE ALL THE- STEPS. IN
THE PROCESS BY THE. YOU'RE NOT
HAVING A- AND BACKGROUND. I
HAVE ACCESS THE TYPES OF. THAT
FAMILIES TYPICALLY. I'M PROVIDE
LIKE BEING A TO ABOUT. I THANK.
TO RELY TRANSIT. AND OF COURSE
GETTING FINANCIAL. FROM FOR AT.
LAW COST. LIKE BUT THE QUIET IN
COMPUTER AND LIVING EXPENSES.
BLACK BECOMES EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING WHEN I CRIED
MICHAEL IN NINETEEN HAPPENED.
BY DESIGNATING THE COST YOU
THIRTY CORNING PROGRAM AS THE
CENTRAL IMMUNITY. TO ENSURE YOU
HAVE SUPPORT WITH PROCESS THIS
BILL WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT. ON THE- ABILITY. TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVERS
YOUR AND I AGREE MORE THAT THE
FAST FOR CAN BE VERY
CHALLENGING TO FILL OUT SO GOOD
FOR YOU FOR FIGURING IT OUT BUT
WE NEED TO HELP EVERYONE BUT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THOSE IN
SUPPORT I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE SO WE
WILL GO TO TWENTY FORTY AND SEE
IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
THERE SEEING NO ONE. WE WILL
NOW GO TO OUR LINES ARE
TELEPHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YES WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN LINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THE MORNING SET
BRAMBLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE PROUD NOT ONLY TO
SUPPORT. SENATOR BELLS SB EIGHT
THANK YOU BUT ALSO THE PRIOR
BILL BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH FIVE SORRY
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WE- ARE
BOOKED. THANK YOU AND NO
WORRIES WE ARE ALL GETTING USED
FOR NEW NORMAL DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. WE DO
LINE TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH WHAT'S
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SHAMPOO OFFICE ON BEHALF OF OUR
BOARD OF GOVERNORS STRONG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
WILL NOW GLOBAL YES WILL GO
LINE TWENTY SIX TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
EIGHT SIXTY FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. WELL NOW
GOT A LINE TWENTY THREE TO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SOVIET
BELIEVE SHAW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK OU WILL MOVE ALONG TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY LINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JESSICA MAXWELL
NATIONAL BENEFIT YOU FLORA WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE EARLY THIRTY EIGHT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT BIND LETTERS
OF SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO ONE TWENTY EIGHT TO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SHARING TOO MANY
MEMBERS MANY OVER THE YEARS ON
BEHALF THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE MORAL TO THE LINE
TWENTY FOUR TWO FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MELISSA
BARTOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT EIGHT COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MY EXHAUST PHONE TWO
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF BEFORE I BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I SEE
NINE HERE TO HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION AND TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE THERE DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. NO
ONE SHOULD UP ON THE PHONE
LINES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANYONE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR PAN. NO.
SENATOR DRAWS. NO I- I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR A BELL AND
ESPECIALLY EMERALD- DURING
THESE VERY VERY DIFFICULT TIMES
WITH BUDGET AND EVERYTHING ELSE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS- I
JUST THERE WILL BE FOCUSED ON-
HOW DO WE HELP THE MOST
VULNERABLE. BECAUSE ALLOWING
MORE PEOPLE TO FALL OVER THAT
CLIFF. IS JUST THAT HAS TO BE
OUR OUR PRIORITY SO- I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF ALL THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE. BUT
ESPECIALLY NOW THANK YOU. THE
USER DRAWS SO BY SURE WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WANTED
THANK CENTER BILL FOR BRING
THIS FORD OF PROUD COOPER THIS
BILL. I KNOW FOR ME. WHEN I WAS
FILLING OUT THE FASTER FORMS
FOR MY KIDS ARE GO ARE YOU
KIDDING ME- IT WAS UNBELIEVABLY
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE DATA ONLY 4% OF
OUR FOX YOU TO GO ON TO
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE SO
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO LIFT UP
THE NEXT GENERATION WE SHOULD
BE DOING. SO THIS IS A VERY
WHERE THE BILL OF SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER. COMMENTS SEEING NONE
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR PAN
MA'AM YES. AMENDMENTS SENATOR
BILL THERE WERE SOME AMENDMENTS
DO YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS WE
ACCEPT THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU EXCELLENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT SIX ZERO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA HI. I SENATOR
WILK HI I SENATOR CHIANG MAI
CHIANG ON A SENATOR DORADO.
TORONTO I SENATOR. MCGUIRE AYE
SENATOR PAN. HI SIX THE BILL IS
OUT SIX ZERO MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE YOU LEAVE WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR BY SENATOR DODD ITEM
FOR SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE THIS
IS THE COMMITTEES OMNIBUS BILL
AN ITEM FIVE SP TWELVE THIRTEEN
WHICH IS FROM THE CHAIR WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR THE CONCERT CALLA
SO MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR LEYVA
HI IF I CENTER WILK HI THE GUY
SENATOR CHIANG MAI CHIANG. I
SENATOR TO ROSA. TORONTO I
CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SENATOR PAN. PAN ON THE BILLS
ON CONSENT OR OUT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THANK YOU TO ALL
THE STAFF WHO MADE THIS HAPPEN
AND MADE IT SO EASY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU UP FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN OUR NEW NORMAL
HAVE A GREAT DAY WE ARE
ADJOURNED. YEAH.